[Music]
Sharia is Islamic law it's derived from
the Quran and the Sunnah that is the way
of Muhammad as derived from the Hadith
the reports on his words and deeds and
the sir his biography it's based on the
quran's numerous commands to obey Allah
and obey the messenger that is Muhammad
Sharia governs every aspect of life it
contains rules for every conceivable
human behavior It Centers on Muhammad's
example as the perfect example of
conduct for Muslims and the model for
emulation in all circumstances it
contains rules for the governing of the
state as well as of individual behavior
and with its denial of the freedom of
speech and the equality of rights for
women and non-muslims it is absolutely
incompatible with the principles and
freedoms of the US Constitution
Muslims are commanded to try to extend
the rule of sharia over all lands Muslim
and non-muslim because it is considered
to be the perfect law of Allah Sharia is
not susceptible to reform or revision
most majority Muslim countries today do
not fully Implement Sharia which causes
some people to mistakenly believe that
there are moderate versions of sharia
that don't call for stoning amputation
beheading and the like but in reality
every form of sharia mandates such
punishments but not all Muslim countries
Implement them now despite all this
Muslims maintain that Sharia is the
Supreme manifestation of justice and
results in a just society when it is
implemented this is because words often
don't mean the same things to Muslims
that they do to westerners Justice in
the Quran does not mean equal treatment
for all people the Quran and Islam in
general doesn't teach that all people
are equal in dignity on the contrary
while it tells Muslims that they are the
best Nation produced as an example for
man sign it says of they who disbelieved
among the people of the scripture and
the polytheists that they are the worst
the most vile of created beings the
Quran directs Muslims not to treat each
group equally but rather to be forceful
against the disbelievers while being
merciful among themselves that is among
fellow
Muslims in line with this the Islamic
law of retaliation or kissas for murder
establishes as a point of law that the
life of a non-muslim does not have the
same value as that of a Muslim and that
a woman's life is not as valuable as a
man's a Sharia manual certified by the
most respected Authority in Sunni Islam
Alazar University in Cairo as conforming
to the practice and Faith of the
Orthodox Sunni community stipulates that
a payment can be made for taking a
woman's life but it's only half of that
to be paid for taking a man's life and
that there's also a sliding scale based
on religious belief if somebody kills a
Jew or a Christian one need pay only
one3 third of that which must be paid
for killing an adult male Muslim now
these are Universal Islamic principles
an Iranian Sufi Muslim cleric shikh
Sultan Hussein taband who was
instrumental in formulating the legal
code for the Islamic Republic of Iran
after the Islamic revolution of 1979
Justified exactly this kind of
inequality in his commentary on the
United Nations Universal Declaration of
Human Rights he said this if a Muslim
deliberately murders another Muslim
he falls under the law of retaliation
and must by law be put to death by the
next of kin but if a non-muslim who dies
at the hand of a Muslim has by lifelong
habit been a non-muslim the penalty of
death is not valid instead the Muslim
murderer must pay a fine and be punished
with the Lash now why is that he
explains because Islam regards
non-muslims is on a lower level of
belief and conviction therefore he says
if a Muslim kills a non-muslim then his
punishment must not be the retaliatory
death since the faith and conviction he
possesses is loftier than that of the
man slain tabanda concludes Islam and
its peoples must be above the infidels
and never permit non-muslims to acquire
lordship over them that
institutionalized inequality and the
devaluation of non-muslim lives is the
Hallmark of sharia for more information
on this go to this website